c'est la position du ni ni ni mado
ronnie gouaille doc a choisi la majorité
des membres de la caricom pas question
de choisir un camp malgré des pressions
l'institution régionale montre de la
retenue même si des états membres ont
déjà pris position pour l'un ou l'autre
des protagonistes venezuela
c'est le cas d'haïti et des bahamas les
seuls au sein de la caricom à
reconnaître le taux proclamé président
point guido suivant ainsi l'exemple de
porto rico et de la république
dominicaine
al'inverse la dominique et saint vincent
affichent clairement leur soutien à
nicolas maduro aux côtés de l'allier
cubain d'autres îles comme sainte lucie
où la jamaïque critique sur la
légitimité de nicolas maduro n'ont pas
franchi le pas de la reconnaissance de
l'opposant comme président onze des
quinze pays membres de la caricom
préfère ne pas s'immiscer dans les
affaires intérieures du venezuela
trinidad barbade antique saint kitts met
en avant le respect de la souveraineté
des états et le principe de non
ingérence non ingérence signifie que
nous nous associons à aucune option
champ d'intervention physique
au venezuela la non-ingérence signifie
que ne soutenons aucun cheval de la
course politique vénézuélien pour la
majorité des pays de la caricom la
reconnaissance de kwh en gouaille d'eau
constitue un précédent extrêmement
dangereux pour le droit international
on s'inquiète aussi des risques de
guerre civile et des répercussions
économiques ou migratoires pour la
caraïbe
la position du ni-ni permet à l'actuel
président de la caricom d'être un acteur
crédible en cas d'éventuelles
négociations
il est très important que ne soient pas
perçues comprenant partie parce que nous
voulons apparaître comme donnant ces
intermédiaires dans ce conflit et ne
pouvaient pas entrer dans un conflit
lorsque votre point de vue vous avez le
temps en particulier comme le mexique et
l'uruguay
la caricom veut mettre les acteurs
vénézuélien autour d'une table
un scénario bien fragile dans le climat
ambiant extrêmement polarisée